nobody here worries about the trash many
people in Haiti are extremely poor
environmental protection is a luxury for
them and yet one person has taken on the
fight against the garbage after studying
in the u.s. jean [ __ ] founded a marine
protection organization and returned to
his homeland go to the beach when I was
younger was pretty clean in most places
but nothing like this I mean this is
just an environmental disaster and it
doesn't just stay here it also travels
through all the oceans it ends up in
other countries and I think we'll have a
real problem in cap-ha tien and
neighboring villages the people live
from fishing the men usually find just
trash in their nets veena wants to
establish a protection zone so fish
stocks can recover there's heavy
overfishing there is an enormous amount
of overfishing going on and that's one
of the issues which we're also trying to
tackle in that they're using
inappropriate methods both in terms of
gear and seasons so we really need to to
get together the men know exactly how
serious the situation is but they need
to keep fishing the situation is tough
the family wants to eat but it's become
difficult to survive everything is more
expensive and we can hardly afford
anything we're hungry because of the
economic misery the situation for nature
keeps getting worse mangroves are being
chopped down burned and processed for
charcoal which is used for cooking
because few people have electricity or
gas beaters organization wants to
provide alternatives like producing new
foods fruit trees are being planted and
sold or given to families it's a simple
solution this doesn't cost much it's not
highly technical and yet a lot of people
just don't seem to be doing it so I
don't know if it's something which
happened culturally down the line but
it's something which we really need to
have people really get much more
involved in
and fishermen could be retrained as
beekeepers so far the teacher has found
just one person interested but the honey
is selling well here in the village
there aren't many people who want to
learn to be beekeepers they're afraid
they'll get stung so far I have just one
gentleman as a student and he's just
started the battle for Haiti's
environment looks hopeless but it has to
be fought without your environment you
have nothing I mean your social
development your economic development
and all of that is linked to having a
sane healthy environment and the
environment in Haiti as far as I'm
concerned is still very much worth
saving he's determined to save his great
love the ocean